Telekom. Einfach Fritzbox abgekackt, ey.
Oh, fuck.
Ich hab dieselben DCs wie du.
Telekom.
Drecks Laden, ey.
Moment, defendet ihr das gerade ohne mich?
Kann das sein?
Ja.
Easy.
Kein C9 jetzt.
Kein C9. Easy.
Okay.
Ja, es lag jetzt nicht in meiner Macht, da was dagegen zu tun.
Telekom.
Ich guck mal, ob der Stream wieder läuft.
Ob der Stream läuft, oder?
Ja.
Oh man, Telekom.
Ja, da sagst du was.
Das ist mega frustrierend.
Ich hatte erst Unity Media.
Mit denen konnte ich, weil ich nicht genug Upload hatte, in ordentlicher Qualität streamen.
Also es wäre theoretisch, hätte das funktioniert.
Allerdings hätte ich maximal 5 MBit gehabt.
So, für den Arsch.
Jetzt hab ich Telekom, hab richtig viel Upload, Bandbreite, VDSL, aber Abbrüche.
Was ist das?
Und so richtig, also es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie paar Pakete verloren gehen.
Das DSL trennt die Synchro, das trennt einfach.
So, ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Ja, ist bei mir auch so.
Drecksladen, ey.
Drei Wochen oder so.
Telekom, ihr habt einen Job, ja?
Ihr habt einen Job.
Den kriegst du dann nicht hin.
Drecksladen.
Hast du nicht auch ab und zu mal ein Paket drin?
So, so immer ganz kurz ein Paket oder so.
Also ich hab manchmal Lacks.
Aber das ist einmal.
Ich hab das immer am Tag gefühlt.
Da springen auch richtig die Helden hier rum.
Was war das nochmal?
N, Steuerung N, Shift N?
Ne, was war das?
Steuerung, Shift N, ja.
Steuerung, Shift N.
Nö, jetzt ist top.
Also ich seh bei mir manchmal dieses Paketverlustzeichen links oben auf.
Ne, das hab ich nie.
Muss man das extra einschalten oder ist das so standardmäßig an?
Das musst du glaub ich einschalten.
Netzwerkhinweise oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, weiß ich, klar. Gucken.
Ich mein ich...
Weißt du was ich machen könnte?
Ich könnte, ich könnte streamen über Telekom, aber das, aber spielen über, über Unity Media.
Oh shit, hier oben bist du dumm.
Ich hab ihn.
Rekt.
Gott sei Dank.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir dich trotzdem verrecken können, ne?
Ey, wo kommt denn jetzt die Ferne her?
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Oh nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh, knapp.
Need help.
Ich bin down.
Lol.
Puh.
Ich versteh das manchmal nicht, wo die Gegner herkommen.
Ich überleg grad, was könnte ich denn anderes spielen?
Hitscan.
Ne, wobei, wir brauchen kein Hitscan.
Wir haben...
Wir haben Widow.
Ja, Strike.
Und Bastion.
Du bist schon wieder dumm, Fist.
Ich kann nix machen von unten. Ich kann pushen.
Was ist das, man?
Ich hab die Symmetra.
Okay, jetzt haben wir sie.
Ja, ich drück die ganze Zeit ein mit Healing, aber es kommen keine Nachrichten.
Und jetzt sagt die mir zu, wenn die Message...
Okay.
So broken, teilweise.
Dachtest schon, der Stream kommt nie wieder?
Ja.
Ey, einfach so abhauen mach ich ja nicht.
Die haben Tele, kann das sein?
Hat sich ausgetealert.
Ich bin gesleapt.
Ja.
Licht-Tour.
Wieder Overwatch.
Diesmal Duo.
Nicht ganz so tilt-lastig.
Wenn die Telekom mitspielt.
Hanzo, hallo.
Der Bastion ist ein wenig nervig.
Oben kommt gleich der dumm Fist.
Der wird gefisst, der dumm Fist, gleich.
Vom Roadhog. Komm her.
Ne, hat keinen Bock.
Haben die Gegner keinen Bock mehr, kann das sein?
Dumm Fist hinter dir.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Der macht nichts anderes,
nichts anderes.
Meteor Strike.
Was, den hab ich nicht getroffen?
Wo ist denn, wo sind denn die Leute?
Der ist schon wieder rechts oben.
Kannst du da rechts hoch gehen, bitte?
Ja.
Wenn ein Held noch low-skilliger ist,
dann der da.
Von einem Stun in den nächsten.
Wo ist der dreckige dumm Fist?
Oh, ich bin gesleapt.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich kann damit nicht viel gegen machen.
Ich kann ihn ab und zu mal hooken.
Aber das war's.
Aber die Gegner
spielen auch schon gar nicht mehr richtig, glaub ich.
Du musst echt mehr Werbung für den Stream machen.
Warum?
But why?
Ich bin doch kein Partner.
Dann lohnt sich das doch nicht mehr.
Er kommt schon wieder zu mir.
Oh!
Help, help, help, help, help, help, help.
Achievement unlocked.
Proof is safe.
Pixels framed.
Der dumm Fist, der...
Geht mir auch mega auf den Sack.
Hast den Held noch.
Hallo, dumm Fist.
Sterben, please.
Ich bräuchte einen Heal.
Hopp.
Und wieso bist du kein Partner?
Weil du keine Werbung für den Stream hast?
Nee, weil ich mich nicht performen hab
und da aktuell auch keine Ambitionen drauf hab.
Also ich versuch jetzt bei dir zu bleiben.
Okay.
Und, ah nee, du hast ihn grad schon gebasht.
Ach komm ey, ich schieß ja alles low.
Sag mal, was ist denn das hier
grad wieder für ne...
Für nen Scheiß?
Mach mal.
Weiß grad nicht, was hier abgeht.
Wie habt ihr das denn
überhaupt defended?
Keine Ahnung.
Hallo, Moira. Du darfst mich heilen, Moira.
Das ist erlaubt.
Hallo. Hallo.
Aber kein Bock drauf.
Okay, wir machen Flankerino.
Mach den Winston weg.
Pushen, pushen, pushen.
Jetzt aber.
Winston am Kart.
Wo ist er?
Nee, ich hab ihn gerockt.
Sag mal, das gibt es doch nicht.
Pushen, pushen, pushen.
Easy.
Gott sei Dank, ey.
Ey, wie habt ihr das gehalten?
Wir sind ja fast, wir sind ja untergegangen gefühlt
grade. Wie habt ihr das zu fünft gehalten?
Frag mich nicht.
Jaja, der mich auch.
Please don't play me. Ja.
Dumpfschwätzer.
Ich hab auch leicht reden, wenn ich nen Loopheld spielen kann.
Mit zehn Stunts.
Vor allem, du hast ja auch nicht wirklich
viel Support gehabt, muss man mal sagen.
Ich hab den ab und zu mal gehuckt, aber das war's.
Kriegt Roadhog auch 50% weniger
Schaden beim Trinken, wenn er lila ist?
Gute Frage. Ich würde vermuten, ja.
Weil sich das lila eigentlich
normalerweise ja nur darauf
bezieht, dass du nicht geheilt werden kannst.
Du hast ja auch
weiterhin Damage Absorb von Rüstung
und sowas.
Also, ich würde mal vermuten,
ja, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert.
Oh, wir haben Instant Game.
Oh, schöne Map.
Tivics Lieblingsmap.
Defense.
Soll ich dich
heilen?
Wobei, Sen, da wär ich weggesniped.
Macht ja keiner was.
Someone, gut Main Tank.
Nein, aber ich spiel ihn trotzdem.
Ich bin kein gut Main Tank.
Der Level 500 Diamond, Hansel.
Der wird's bestimmt bringen.
Der geht ab.
Das sind ja immer die Spieler,
die da teilweise mehr Playtime haben
als die Pros in zwei Jahren.
Die haben...
Tivic ist...
Oder war das Tivic?
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendjemand hat letztens im Stream
mal Silber gekriegt.
Also Silberrang.
Ja.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Dieses Symbol unten.
Wo es dann so silber wird.
Und das nach zwei Jahren Spielen.
Patrick, normalerweise wird schon
mehr gelabert in Game, aber ich bin
die ganze Zeit nicht im Voice Chat gewesen.
Ich geh auch wieder raus, weil
es wird schwierig, mich darauf
zu konzentrieren.
Da mach ich nix
mit meinem Schild, solange da nix reinkommt.
Der Winston.
Rotor kommt unten links lang.
Unten links, unten links der Rotor.
Da kann einer die Mercy wechseln.
Pharah ist links.
WTF?
Help!
Schild bricht, Schild bricht.
Ich brauch Heal!
Heal, please!
Ah, ich werd auch endlich mal geheilt.
Okay, Barrier ist kaputt.
Ich muss mich mal verpissen.
Das ist richtig kaputt gegangen.
Ich wollt grad ein Schild hochnennen.
Ach, wir haben gar keine Mercy.
WTF?
Dachte.
Dachte, wir haben eine Mercy.
Der Nano boostet
an so.
Ach, wir haben jetzt den
Spacko im Team.
Scheint. Ich switch mal D.Va.
Sonst wird das nix.
Ich hab die Pharah erwischt
mit dem Fire Strike, aber
mehr ging da nicht.
Wer ist denn der Spacko?
Okay, das könnte was werden.
Wir müssen bloß auf dem Punkt bleiben.
Nice, dann. Sehr, sehr nice.
Hälfte daneben geschossen.
Ich switch wieder auf was mit Schild.
Zeig mal, was haben die denn?
Eigentlich brauchen wir nicht so wirklich ein Schild, ne?
Die haben Flanker, die haben noch
Pharah, Roadhog.
Ich bleib mal auf D.Va.
So richtig großartig. Poke Damage haben die net.
Moment!
Warum sterben alle?
Keine Heilung, wieder mal.
Absorgen.
Was willst du denn da machen, ey?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Da ging jetzt wirklich nicht so viel.
Gucken, Spiel Support.
Wieder meine ultrakrassen...
Komm, jetzt
wird der Zen ausgepackt.
Nein, jetzt wird nicht der Zen ausgepackt.
Die Mercy wird ausgepackt.
Ja, okay.
Kackheld, ey. Ich hoffe, die Nerven
sind so kaputt, dass ihn keiner
mal spielen will.
Also...
Was heißt spielen will?
Spielen muss.
Von spielen will kann man hier keine Rede sein.
So.
Völlig isoliert. Chat aus, Voice aus.
Perfekt.
Hast du schon
mit Qt gearbeitet? Ja.
Doch. Ich lese aber grad
meinen Chat. Das ist interessanter.
Also Evoli hab ich, ja.
Signal Slots ist ein bisschen wie
Event, sind sie sharp.
Das ist gewöhnungsnah.
So eine Idee, wie man Mercy balancen könnte.
Also Neba einfach so scheiße machen,
dass sie raus, dass sie keiner mehr spielt.
Ja, was meinst du?
Alle Patches löschen
bis zum 50% Discord auf.
Dann spielt sie auch keiner mehr.
Das ist glaube ich...
Aber das ist glaube ich kein
realistischer
Ansatz.
Wtf hier steht...
Was?
Die Diamond-Blogic muss ich
erstmal gewinnen.
Ich... Hallo! Oh fuck!
Der geht rein!
Okay, ich geh jetzt mit unserem Roadhog.
Go Roadhog! Move dich!
Sag mir mal wo du bist.
Oben auf der Wand, auf der Mauer.
Okay.
Auf! Moved euch! Moved euch Leute! Moved euch!
Da ist ein Reaper
direkt über uns, ne?
Ja. Ich hasse diesen Held.
Ich hasse ihn so sehr.
Drecks Held. Moment, das ist kein...
Oh! Oh!
Ich...
Perfekter Mercy-Play!
Perfekter Mercy-Play, Max!
Man sieht schon, wie oft ich...
Und wie haben wir den Fight eigentlich verloren?
Was geht mit der Mercy ab?
Ja, Damage Boost.
Roadhog, Roadhog, ich kann nicht zu dir fliegen.
Ich seh nix. Danke, Hanzo.
Ja, Hanzo.
Reaper kommt da.
Ich wette, du merkst, wie cool Mercy ist, wenn du Mercy mainst.
Ich sag euch eins.
Ich werde nie im Leben vorher deinstalliere ich Overwatch,
bevor ich Mercy maine.
So ein Kack-Held.
Kannst du mich healen?
Wenn du auch Damage Boost geben würdest.
Ja, mach ich.
Äh, nein, mach ich nicht.
Von da und jetzt Damage Boost, bitte.
Ich komm... muss zu dir hoch.
Ich komm nicht zu dir hoch.
Roadhog ist down.
Ich muss mal kurz unseren Typ heilen.
Echt jetzt?
Der Reaper hat gerade den Full-Hedge überlebt.
Macht das nicht 300?
Ach, da kommt was zu dir hoch.
Äh, nein.
Vergiss es, kommt's nicht.
Wieso ist denn keiner auf dem Spot?
Ich hab gerade vier Leute gesnipert.
Weil keiner da ist.
Jetzt hab ich nen Genji auf mir drauf.
Kannst du mich heilen? Hinter dir?
Ach, die haben einen She-Gen.
Deswegen ist der Reaper nicht draufgegangen.
Die Mercy plays, the plays!
Nein!
Was macht denn die Moira? Kann die auch mal was heilen?
Oh man, der Genji.
So ne Ulte, bich.
Ich frag mich,
der Fight ging doch wieder fünf Minuten, weißt du?
Hat eigentlich keiner den She-Gen down gemacht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ich war zu sehr damit beschäftigt,
mich, äh, auf diesen
Hero hier zu konzentrieren.
Um huge Mercy-Plays zu machen.
Ich bleib jetzt mal auf dir drauf.
Die war keine.
Also, also, also.
Ich muss mal die Leute heilen.
Ich geh mal auf den Spot.
Oh, was?
Easy.
Die Mercy.
Die Mercy, das ist so krass, oder?
Du bist unsterblich.
Du, Movement des Todes,
kannst wiederbeleben,
heilst dich selbst
und machst Damage.
Warum?
Nein.
Ich mach keine Mercy mehr.
Ich fühl mich richtig dreckig,
wenn ich Mercy spiele.
Übrigens, ähm,
hast du die Maywall am Ende gesehen?
Ja, ja.
Die Maywall hat eben das Game verloren, ne?
Richtig schlecht.
Widow, hast du einen Mann getötet?
Ich hab alles auf Gold,
wenn du so blöd fragst.
Oh, Mann, ey.
Der Typ ist einfach nur unter der Ebene.
Can you stop bullying our good player?
Schreibt der andere jetzt.
Zur Wand so.
Keks, can I hog?
Ja, kannst du. Du kannst hoggen.
Ich spiel jetzt Ana.
Ich spiel jetzt keine Mercy mehr.
Easy.
Warum zockst du nicht eigentlich Lucio stattdessen?
Du bist doch viel geiler.
Ja, wir haben, weil wir keinen Heal haben sonst.
Wir haben ne Moira. Meinst du, die heilt irgendwas?
Mit Lucio geht das ja auch.
Wenn du das sagst, ich lass mir das dann zweimal sagen, Lucio zu spielen.
Bringst halt die Leute rein
und, ja.
Warum sind eigentlich alle so scharf drauf,
links zu gehen?
Immer.
Okay, ich geh mal vor.
Es war ein bisschen spät.
Weiß ja, wenn keiner so ein Schild da macht,
dann kann ich nix machen.
Und zwar wirklich nichts.
Was?
Womit?
Wo ist der Affe hin?
Schwing grad mit rein.
Zack, Affe weg.
Ich bin übrigens tot.
Weil ich reingejoloed bin.
Ich komm zu dir.
Hi.
Oh Gott, ey.
Muss ich jetzt wirklich wechseln?
Fuck, Alter.
Da macht ja keiner was.
Ja, komm, wir speedboosten da jetzt rein
und dann geht's aufs Maul.
So wirklich gut funktioniert das mit Lucio
nicht wirklich.
Das ist sowas von schlimm.
Wenn du zwei
Tanks einpackst, da ist so viel,
so viele Schilde, da kommst du gar nicht mehr durch.
Das ist sowas von gespammt, ey.
Der Hanzo wird übrigens
tot geflamed.
Echt?
Immerhin war ich nicht mehr geflammt.
Du wirst gar nicht.
Nur der kack Hanzo hat dich geflammt.
Also der Typ, der halt wirklich gar nichts geschissen
kriegt gerade.
Du kriegst, du kriegst.
Alles was ich hab.
Nice, du nice. Und jetzt drauf.
Speed läuft.
Ich ulte da jetzt, gleich rein.
Das ist...
Die Mei?
Oh fuck. Hinter dir, hinter dir.
Bisschen Gage noch
kriegt man nicht.
Ich probier's.
Nein, nein, nein, okay.
Nochmal regroupen.
Recrupsorn, Leute.
Das ist voll für den Arsch.
Diese ganze Schildkiste.
Das geht mir so auf den Sack.
Wenn dir der Dinger keiner down macht,
dann hast du voll gelitten.
Okay, okay, okay. Nicht sterben, Leute.
Nicht sterben.
Wir uns spot contesten.
Go, ja.
Fuck. Fu, fu, fu, fu.
Ah, ja.
Hätte ein bisschen weiterhüpfen müssen.
Okay.
Wie viel haben wir gekriegt?
Haben wir überhaupt ein bisschen was gekriegt?
Nix. Gar nix?
Wird hier erst auf
33% gezählt.
Hm. Ist aber dumm.
Ja, das find ich
auch ein bisschen traurig, weil im Prinzip
müssen sie ja alles tracken.
Ja.
Aber nee, es muss ja ein Trauer werden können.
Das ist aber echt dumm.
Ich dachte,
ich dachte eigentlich,
in Overtime,
also was heißt in Overtime, quasi ab der zweiten Runde
oder so, ist dann wirklich so
nicht mehr durchkommen, sondern halt
tatsächlich jedes Prozent getrackt.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Leute im Chat,
das wollt ihr nicht suchen. Glaubt mir.
Das wollt ihr nicht suchen.
Es sei denn, ihr wollt fürs Leben danach
geprägt
sein durch sowas.
Es gibt Sachen,
da weiß man doch
mittlerweile im Jahr 2017 schon,
bevor man sucht, wie es ausgeht.
Und wenn man nach solchen Begriffen sucht
in Google, da weiß man, oder in Google vielleicht
nicht unbedingt,
da weiß man doch schon, wie es ausgeht.
Die werden jetzt wieder rumspringen.
Musst du mir halt ansagen, wenn du das siehst.
Fahrer, ich seh ne Fahrer.
Moment, was ist das hier?
Ich weiß nicht, sind die
rechts durch? Hast du was gesehen?
Ich seh nämlich kaum noch was. Ja, rechts, rechts.
Ich geh wieder, ich bin wieder Main.
Maze, Maze richtig low.
Ich hab den Firestrike verkackt.
Die kriegen wir, die kriegen wir.
Ja, rechts seid ihr gerade bloß eingerissen.
Über uns in der Mitte ne Fahrer.
Jawoll, down.
Hier wird
hier wird gehämmert.
Diese scheiß Kugel da oben.
Keine Widow am Start.
Ich weiß nicht, gehen sie rechts? Sag mal bitte, ob sie
rechts gehen. Links, links, links. Links?
Links nicht.
Links sloppy.
Ja, Hass.
Was?
Oh ne.
Ich bed Funk.
Ich brauche activities henceforth Firesetime.
Oh, ich wollte gerade Firestrike'n.
Kacke.
Fuck, schnupp, schnupp.
Wir sind die einzigen, die hier am Bremsen sind.
und fire sind wir ja.
Das waren recht solide Reinhardt-Plays,
muss ich sagen.
Ich hab wieder Shatter, klar.
Jetzt kannst du ein Draw werden.
Sehr geil.
Richtig motivierend sowas.
Oh, dann los.
Ich glaub, die gehen links. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber ich glaub, ich hab die links gesehen.
So, Shatter. Shatter wieder am Start.
Huge. Fett Shatter kommt jetzt.
Richtig fett.
Ich guck mir keine random Videos an,
die irgendjemand im Chat postet, zu denen schon gesagt wird,
ich soll mal reacten.
Das kann ja schon mal nix Gutes sein.
Das kann ja schon mal irgendein Blödsinn sein.
Ach komm, ey.
Huge Shatter.
Huge.
Ey, was ist das bitte für eine Hitbox?
Sag mal, kommt da noch jemand?
Das war der...
Das war der Shatter auf Doom, ey.
...die auf dem Boden lag.
Bodyhit. Einfach nur ein Bodyhit.
Ey, das war der Shatter,
das Tod ist gerade. Da waren sechs Leute oder so drinnen.
Ja, hab's gesehen.
Oh man, ey.
Bleib mal drin.
Naja.
Easy.
27%.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass sechs andere Leute in dem Team sind, ne?
Okay, zu was soll ich reacten?
Zu welchem Video?
Guck da jetzt mal kurz rein.
Was ist das?
Zum Glück hab ich so einen Vorschauplagen.
Das zeigt dir gleich an, bevor du es aufmachst, was es ist.
Money Boy. Monte Carlo.
Offizielles Musikvideo.
Money Boy.
Moment, der Typ heißt doch gar nicht mehr Money Boy, oder?
Heißt der jetzt nicht irgendwie Pluck, Black, J, J, Pluck, oder irgendwie so?
Pluck?
Was? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Aber anscheinend heißt er wieder Money Boy.
Er spielt Golf.
Nee, der hat's doch unbenannt.
Der heißt doch nicht mehr Money Boy.
Der hat's doch unbenannt jetzt zu...
Genau, wie sein YouTube-Channel heißt.
JSL No Pluck.
Alter, was ist das für Musik?
Muss man das irgendwie auf 125% Wiedergabegeschwindigkeit stellen, dass das normal klingt?
Oh, das ist ja schlimm.
Nee, das kann ich mir nicht antun.
Wir spielen jetzt lieber Gibraltar.
Mal kacke genug Money Boy geguckt.
Jawoll, schön auch noch ein Attack.
Aber eigentlich ist im Roadhog hier kacke.
Verlegen wir, wir können Winston spielen.
Mal da hochhüpfen.
Ich probier's doch mal mit Roadhog, aber nein, ich muss...
Guck mal, was ich spielen muss!
Was machst du?
Ich spiel als Allah.
Sag mal, warum gibt's zu wenig Mercy-Mains auf Diamond?
Weil die alle schon Grand-Maths sind.
Ich mein, auf GM hast du mittlerweile Games, da hast du zwei Mercy-Mains, die sich dann anbitchen, wer jetzt Mercy spielen darf, ja?
Und hier, wer muss hier Mercy spielen?
Mr. Fantastic spielt jetzt Mercy.
Pass auf, der Genji-Main ist Genji-Main, der spielt bestimmt Mercy.
Nein, Moira.
Ich guck mal, ich guck mal.
Ich guck mal, ich halt das denn aus mit Mercy.
Das ist wirklich Folter.
Der Anna-Carry war vorhin real.
Auf 2 CP, das geht schon.
6 Leute, das hat einer in mein Chatter geklippt.
Der sagt, es waren keine 6 Leute.
Mal gucken, wie viele es waren.
Waren's nur 3 oder was?
2 Stück.
Warte mal.
4, okay, es waren 4.
Es waren 4.
Ups, was geht los?
Nein, nein, ich bin noch nicht da, ich bin noch nicht da.
Mr. Fun.
Mr. Fantastic, ich muss mal die, die hier heilen, hier drinnen.
Hast du was? Hast du was gepickt?
Mr. Ja, die Tricer.
Mr. Ah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Mr. Ui, und da ist der McCree weg.
Mr. Sehr schön. Sag mal, wenn du hinter mir was siehst, ich guck mal vorne mit unserem Roadhog.
Mr. Das ist ein guter Roadhog, der macht wenigstens einen Schild da.
Mr. Erhält mir.
Mr. Scatter, Scatter.
Ich hab Ulti, klar?
Mr. Äh, da hab ich nicht drauf geachtet, sorry.
Mr. Nee, ich hab ja nen Headshot bekommen, falls du eh nichts machen könntest.
Mr. Ich hab Ulti am Start.
Mr. Tecci Vocaro!
Mr. Huge Sleep!
Mr. Alter, wie viele Sniper haben die denn?
Mr. Du musst mir sagen, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich dich heilen soll.
Mr. Ich guck grad eher zu unseren Tanks vor.
Mr. Was?
Mr. Ihr müsst halt echt büschen mit uns da vorne.
Mr. Huge Sleep.
Mr. Ich glaube, wir bräuchten mal einen Sonsraver an den Tank.
Mr. Wir haben so viele Striper dagegen.
Mr. Ich glaub's nicht.
Mr. Ich bin da, ich bin da alleine drinne, ne?
Mr. Ihr müsst, ihr müsst pushen.
Mr. Ich glaub, die rennen mir nach.
Mr. Der Reinhardt schläft unten.
Mr. Die sind alle unten! Die sind alle unten bei mir!
Mr. Hieeeelp!
Mr. Ich bin übrigens tot, ich kann dich nicht heilen.
Mr. Das, das, der hätten wir so oft schon durch sein müssen jetzt grade.
Mr. Kannste Genji spielen oder sowas?
Mr. Echt jetzt?
Mr. War noch nicht mal sichtbar.
Mr. WTF? Ihr stirbt!
Mr. Ihr seid alle instant!
Mr. NEIN! DIVA DU DUMME!
Mr. OOOOH!
Mr. Jutschli... Nein, jetzt werden sie auch noch aufgeweckt.
Mr. Ich glaub's nicht.
Mr. Warum machen wir einfach so die Bombe?
Mr. Diva ist das einzige gescheite Nanoboost-Target, was ich hab.
Mr. So.
Mr. Muss halt auch die Mercy rausgeholt werden.
Mr. Es wär halt echt nicht schlecht, wenn wir was zum Diven haben.
Mr. Das, das war eigentlich der Hintergedanke.
Mr. Da hab ich mir gedacht, du boostest jetzt den Nanoboost, das ist jetzt die Diva.
Mr. Die fliegt rein, macht ein bisschen Action.
Mr. Killt was? Nope.
Mr. Schretzt den Typ mal.
Mr. Nein, nein, ich hab einen Tracer auf mir.
Mr. Wo bist du?
Mr. Null.
Mr. Tracer kommt.
Mr. Verlieren wir das jetzt noch?
Mr. Was? Sieht so aus...
Mr. Also DPS hat ja keiner mehr.
Mr. Es stirbt ja auch keiner.
Mr. Was machen die denn? Da fuck!
Mr. WTF?
Mr. Oh Mann, was ne Pfeife.
Mr. Ich geh vom Widow runter, weil ich keinen Impact mit so einem Start-up.
Mr. Und dann geht er auf Widow.
Mr. Also ich kann ja wenig grad machen, ne?
Mr. Also...
Mr. Der Heil-Output eben war nicht mal normal.
Mr. WAH!
Mr. She baited.
Mr. Nice! Nice! Ninja Cap!
Mr. Ninja Cap.
Mr. Nice.
Mr. Die machen halt alle nicht so viel. Ja, das stimmt!
Mr. Ich bin übrigens tot.
Mr. Schretzt dich, schretzt dich.
Mr. Easy, easy, schretzt.
Mr. Scheiß drauf.
Mr. Sind Noobs. Fuck.
Mr. Ich dachte mir, die treffen bestimmt nicht.
Mr. Auch wenn ich als Mercy 20 Sekunden stillstehe.
Mr. Scheiß drauf.
Mr. Ich mein, es ist ja nur ein Hanzo und eine Widow.
Mr. Die müssen ja eigentlich nur einmal drauf.
Mr. Aber, ja.
Mr. No Balls.
Mr. No Win.
Mr. NEIN!
Mr. Cool.
Mr. Da konnt ich dann hin.
Mr. Anna gibt mir auch keine Ahnung.
Mr. Das ist auch absolut overrated.
Mr. She baited.
Mr. Rechts ist Sniper, rechts ist Sniper.
Mr. Easy.
Mr. Also ich sag dir ehrlich.
Mr. Ich find die Games viel anstrengender als alles andere.
Mr. Was findest du anstrengender?
Mr. Diese Low Rank Games.
Mr. Das ist übel.
Mr. Das ist voll der Brainfuck.
Mr. Egal.
Mr. Die Leute.
Mr. Ich seh schon wieder komisch, was wir aus dem Spiel haben.
Mr. Geiler Comment im Chat.
Mr. Egal, ob ihr die Runde verliert oder gewinnt.
Mr. Immerhin konntest du ein bisschen deinen Lieblingsheld spielen.
Mr. Jawoll.
Mr. Easy.
Mr. Ich hab schon irgendwie Folter für manche Spieler.
Mr. Stell dir mal vor, du spielst deinen Raum ein.
Mr. Alles was du tun wusstest, wirst du spielen.
Mr. Ich wär jetzt geflamed.
Mr. Shit.
Mr. Ähm.
Mr. Ja gut, was soll ich denn machen?
Mr. Bleibt ja nix anderes übrig.
Mr. Support dich auch mal.
Mr. Jawoll, komm her.
Mr. Support zu Duo des Todes.
Mr. Ist wenigstens die Heilung an sich.
Mr. Wenn die keinen...
Mr. Keinen Genji...
Mr. Ja, wenn die
Mr. bisschen, bisschen was
Mr. weniger Aggressives spielen,
Mr. geh ich vielleicht auf Zen.
Mr. Zen macht übelst Bock.
Mr. Ist eigentlich von den Supportern so mit der,
Mr. der mir am meisten noch Spaß macht.
Mr. Ist halt...
Mr. Wenn du gar keinen hast, der dich ein bisschen protectet,
Mr. kannst du knicken.
Mr. Bin mal gespannt,
Mr. wer zur ersten Headshot frisst.
Mr. Also ich tippe...
Mr. Auf Mr. Fantastic.
Mr.
Mr. Mr. Fantastic.
Mr. Tipp auf dich.
Mr. Auf mich? Das kann auch sein.
Mr. Nee, guck mal, ich hab die ADAD-Skills.
Mr. Mir passiert nix.
Mr. Und auch...
Mr. Ich kann auch das weggucken, dass mein Kopf nicht trifft.
Mr. Ich Damage booste dich jetzt.
Mr. Die haben Hanzo.
Mr. Oh nee.
Mr. Scatter, scatter.
Mr. Scatter.
Mr. Ich bin runter getroppt übrigens,
Mr. weil ich mir dachte so, hä, passt schon.
Mr. Mr. Fantastic, fast tot gewesen.
Mr. Jo.
Mr. Jetzt müssen wir weg hier.
Mr. Mr. Fantastic, wo ist er denn hin?
Mr. Da hinten.
Mr. Oh, wieder oben.
Mr. Den krieg ich net, den krieg ich net.
Mr. Eventuell doch.
Mr. Nope.
Mr. Alle purple.
Mr. Oh, die wieder.
Mr. Puh.
Mr. Hast du nen Herzschlag bekommen?
Mr. Nee, ich war low.
Mr. Ich war low.
Mr. Ich dachte mir, ich probier ihn zu retzen, weißt du?
Mr. Und das war nix.
Mr. Max, du hast eine sexy Stimme.
Mr. Kappa Pride.
Mr. Voll Kappa Pride.
Mr. Welcher Rang ist mein Main?
Mr. Ich hab's seit Season 3 immer gespielt.
Mr. 3900 oder so.
Mr. Mr. Fantastic, kann ich geheilt werden?
Mr. Wo ist eigentlich Mr. Fantastic?
Mr. Ich seh die Leiche nicht.
Mr. Mr. Lover, Lover.
Mr. Oh, ist das spannend Mercy, oder Leute?
Mr. Ist das nicht geil?
Mr. 360 Damage Boost.
Mr. Wett.
Mr. Moment, ich hab meine Ult gar nicht gebraucht, ne?
Mr. Also.
Mr. Hinter uns ist ne D.Va.
Mr. Die kommt zu mir, heimlich, heimlich.
Mr. Easy, easy, easy, Bärchen.
Mr. Ist weg.
Mr. Also die Ult war sinnlos.
Mr. Ich dachte, da stirbt gleich jemand.
Mr. Aber, nope.
Mr. Oh fuck, fuck, wo?
Mr. Weiß ich nicht, war ein Scattershot.
Mr. High Skill.
Mr. High Octane Gameplay.
Mr. Äh.
Mr. Ah!
Mr. Damage Boost, solcher.
Mr. Mr. Fantastic ist verreckt.
Mr. Der Hanzo kann doch nicht mal
Mr. seine Ult auf den Grav aimen.
Mr. Aua, Sombra.
Mr. Piss dich, Alde.
Mr. Scatter, Scatter.
Mr. Ui.
Mr. Itzi.
Mr. High Octane Mercy Gameplay.
Mr. Easy.
Mr. Kaum hast du zwei gute Heiler.
Mr. Schon stehen die Leute
Mr. wie so ein Stein, weißt.
Mr. Ich bewerb mich jetzt
Mr. am besten noch.
Mr. Chat, welches Team hat noch offene
Mr. offene Slots OVL?
Mr. Wer braucht noch Support?
Mr. Naja, Mercy Main EU.
Mr. Number one.
Mr. Guck hier. Easy.
Mr. So ein dummer Held.
Mr. Ja, ich lade dich wieder ein.
Mr. Mir fällt gerade auf, es ist schon 23.30 Uhr.
Mr. Aber egal. Ich hab eh Urlaub.
Mr. Ich hab Urlaub.
Mr. Warst du nie so lange wach.
Mr. Noch nie.
Mr. In meinen 33 Jahren war ich noch nie.
Mr. Bis 23.30 Uhr.
Mr. Nie.
Mr. Muss ich jetzt was futtern, sonst geht das nicht.
Mr. Ich nehm das jetzt auf.
Mr. Drei erreichten Massive Gameplay hochladen.
Mr. Warum sind eigentlich noch so viele Leute on?
Mr. Was ist hier los?
Mr. 2 CP.
2 CP. Pablo.
Ich sag eigentlich immer so
Soldier, Sixty, nein, nein, nein.
Alternativ hättest du auch irgendwie
Soldier, äh,
ach, fuck, wie hieß das?
420, genau.
Soldier, 420 hättest du auch noch machen können.
Aber da werden mir
nicht so coole Sachen eingefallen, wie die Kombination
hier. Aber dann sollte
sich wirklich mal Winso
als Nick machen, dann spielst du
nur wieder und Hanzo.
Winso.
Moment.
Wir sind Defense. Warum hab ich
jetzt... Egal.
Ich dachte, wir sind Attack.
Wurscht.
Dann werden sie gefistet hier.
Rekt!
Bis jetzt.
Da kommt die wieder 50 Jahre später.
Wenn nicht gewiss.
Ähm, bei mir sind 50 Milliarden
Gegner gerade.
Weil irgendwie auf einmal
alle Leute weg waren. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Warum waren
alle Leute weg auf einmal?
Ähm.
Ich hab irgendwie das dumpfe Gefühl,
D.Va ist besser.
Ja, ist schon verloren.
Yeah. Geht gut los.
Sag mal, haben wir überhaupt DPS? Wir haben...
Naja.
Ich könnte Soldier gehen. Ich geh jetzt mal Soldier.
Irgendwie hab ich das
so im Urin, dass das gut funktioniert.
Oh, unser Reiner hat grad geswitcht, okay.
Oh! Fuck.
Jetzt haben wir kein Tank mehr.
Ja, das...
Naja.
Wo ist die Widow?
Oh.
Moira ist bei uns.
Im Spawn. Und in der Tracer. Und...
Sag mal, hier ist ja alles voll!
Alter, was ist denn das hier für ne Dominanz?
Ey.
Du weißt gar nicht, wo du hingucken sollst. Auf allen Fronten sterben sie.
Ich jump jetzt drauf.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ulti, nice, ulti. Wat?
Hüüü.
Ich hab gleich weißer.
Brauchen wir aber, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Äh, Defense, Matrix.
2CP, lol. Eins hätten sie das haben müssen,
wenn es nicht so ein Kackmodus wäre.
Tracer kommt von rechts, unten.
Okay, ich bin...
Ich hab sie.
Die Moira ist... Moira haut ab, rechte Seite.
Oder...
Es könnte sein, dass sie noch rechte...
Die Moira ist rechte Seite drin, die holen wir jetzt.
Moira, ey, Alter, was für ein Damage macht das denn nicht normal?
Ich brauch Heal.
Hier. Oh, nein, ich hab nix mehr, ich hab nix mehr.
Zwei Sekunden, zwei Sekunden, zwei Sekunden.
So.
Easy, wir machen das jetzt selbst.
Da kann uns... uns heilt keiner.
Bastion!
Jetzt kommen die mit dem Bastion?
Was?
Ah, fuck!
Das bringt denen aber, glaube ich, nicht so viel.
Wir müssen einfach außer Sicht stehen bleiben.
Hashtag einfach.
Oh!
Tank, das war das schlechteste, was passieren konnte.
Fuck!
Warum bin ich jetzt...
Oh, ich noob.
Ich noob.
Ich bin voll auf den Bastion zugerannt.
Warum?
Ach so, weil ich aus der... aus der Diva-Ult wollte, ja.
Aber da hätte ich in die andere Richtung rennen müssen.
Total bescheuert.
Die andere...
Wobei, es hätte nichts gebracht.
Es hätte nichts...
Es hätte...
Egal, welche Richtung.
Die andere Richtung hätte nichts gebracht.
Ah, was für Games, ey.
Komm, ich spiel jetzt mal einen Damage.
Easy.
Sie winnen.
Es fehlen echt keine Mercy-Spieler, ne?
Was...
Was ist denn das?
Oh, Mann!
So.
Leute, High-Octane-Gameplay ist angebracht.
Die...
Kann das...
Das...
Du hast es ja vorhin so aus Scheiß ges...
Also aus Spaß gesagt, ne?
Kann das sein, dass die halbwegs guten Mercy-Mains wirklich schon alle Campmaster sind?
Es gibt keine guten Mercy-Mains.
Kannst du das unterlassen?
Hahaha.
Das könnte sein.
Das...
Das stimmt, was du gesagt hast.
Deswegen gibt's hier keine Mercy-Mains mehr.
Wesker, Late-Game-Stream...
Äh...
Late...
Late-Stream.
Ja.
Mit...
Mit Telekom-Fail dazwischen.
Das ist jetzt neues Meta, hier...
Hier rauszugehen, oder wie?
Wir machen...
Mercy.
Wir machen jetzt Damage-Mercy.
Das ist...
Das geht mir schon echt auf den Sack, dass ich heute so viel Mercy spielen muss.
Gut.
Also...
Die Mercy ist stillgestanden.
Ich hab ihr in den Kopf gedrückt.
Body shot.
Kommst du durch?
Oder willst du nicht durch?
Rebind uns.
Ja.
Ich seh's.
Ich muss aber unsere Leuten hinterher...
Leute!
Reinhardt, du musst da vorgehen!
Das ist dir schon klar, oder?
Der Reinhardt suckt.
Haha.
False.
Äh...
Rein...
Oh Gott.
Was ist das hier?
Oh.
Zwei Picks.
Ich bleibe auf dir.
Easy.
Äh.
Hä?
Warum ging der Retz jetzt bitteschön nicht?
What the fuck?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo du bist.
Wo bist du?
Oben.
Oben?
Ah, da.
So.
Wir gehen jetzt rein.
Die haben...
Die haben Bastion drin.
Schon wieder.
Ich hab in den Kopf geschossen.
So.
Easy.
Ich hab ihn gekillt.
Body shot.
Was?
Ich versteh das nicht.
Was ist mit der Hittrick am Arsch, ey?
Weiß nicht.
Hab gleich ult.
Ich weiß übrigens, warum das Ding nicht geretzt hat, eben.
Ich glaub, man darf eh nicht gedrückt halten, wenn man schon mal drauf war und dann wieder rausgelaufen ist.
Sondern muss...
Neu eh drücken.
Weil da die Anzeige ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Aber ich bin halt einfach Mercy-Main erster Stunde, ne?
Sozusagen DER Mercy-Main EU.
Äh, ich bin übrigens bei uns im Reinhardt unten gerade.
Der jetzt mal draufgehen muss.
Okay.
Ich...
Ohhhh.
Blablabla.
Meine Mercy-Plays.
Da chokt er.
Chok-Mercy.
Ich wär so froh, wenn jemand anderes Mercy spielen würde.
Oh ja.
Komm, Reinhardt. Reinhardt.
Jetzt.
Jetzt wirst du gehealt.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Würdest du mal mehr Mercy spielen?
Nein!
Oh, Bastion, Bastion.
Ey, der Moira-Ball, der killt mich.
Der ist schon seit ner Stunde da am rumfliegen.
Reinhardt, swing!
Swing!
Äh, ich...
Ich versuch hochzukommen zu dir.
Willst du?
Nein.
Kann ich nicht.
Fuck.
Aber wir müssen es auch so packen.
Meine Mercy-Plays, äh...
Jetzt nen Nurse-Shutter, wo alles schon tot ist.
Es frustriert mich so, nix machen zu können und Mercy spielen zu müssen.
Also zwei hab ich wenigstens.
Ja, zusammen sind aber alle tot.
Jo.
Ich geh jetzt mit dir oben rechts.
Eigentlich haben wir noch nen zweiten Heiler, ne?
Eigentlich.
Ein Genji ist hinter uns.
Wer nicht?
Ich stream schon relativ oft in letzter Zeit.
Mercy, please.
Ich will noch was anderes spielen.
Krasse ult, Pablo.
Massive ult.
Massive.
Ich hab Fenster.
Ey, die gehen nur auf mich.
Reinhardt, hallo.
Reinhardt.
Alle wieder geretzt.
Go, go.
Easy clap.
Easy.
Können wir mal rein?
Nein, können wir anscheinend nicht.
ETF.
Come on, fire.
Jetzt aber.
Ich, ich.
Damage booste dich jetzt.
Easy.
Machste platt.
So.
Ich bleibe einfach bei dir stehen.
Hinter, hinter uns, hinter uns ist ne Moira.
Rechts, Soldier.
Damage boost.
Easy.
Achtung.
Genji rechts.
Hahaha.
Schreckt.
Einfach nur schreckt.
Hardcore schreckt.
Das machen wir jetzt immer so.
Ich spiel Mercy, du spielst Widow und ich stell mich einfach neben dich und mach Damage boost.
Genau.
Das, ich, ich, ich.
Ich meine, man muss doch ehrlich sagen.
Das ist für nen Stream auch das Beste.
Da kann ich nämlich ordentlich Fragen im Chat beantworten, während ich das mache.
Also das verbindet, das, das, das verbindet quasi das Beste aus zwei Welten.
Oh man.
So.
Mal gucken, was jetzt, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich keine Mercy picke.
Wir verlieren.
Hahaha.
Meinst du?
Ja, natürlich.
Warum?
Ich will was ordentliches spielen.
Ey, mich wundert das.
Wir haben die ganze Zeit nen Junkrat im Team.
Aber ich bin Gold-Damaged.
Aber was macht der die ganze Zeit?
Als ob du mit Widow Gold kriegst.
Hey, guck mal.
Ich bin Mercy und bin nur Bronze-Heal, ja?
Aber ich hab ja auch die ersten zwei Runden keine Mercy gespielt.
Oh Mann ey.
Ja, du musst ja eh nicht heilen, wenn er auf mir Damage boostet.
Nee, das ist kein Ding.
Easy.
Dann brauch ich schon Heal.
Heal ist das absolut overrated.
Outdated, eliminated, overrated, jebaited ist Heal.
Wie ob da ein Play of the Game von mir dabei ist am Ende.
Ich hoff's.
Das war richtig geil.
Du hast dich übelst weggesprayt da unten.
Also, was heißt gesprayt?
Geklickt.
Weggeklickt.
Klickt.
Warte, der Genji hat schön ins Gesicht bekommen.
Ich komm nicht hoch zu dir.
Jetzt.
Easy, easy.
Genji hinter mir.
Die haben schon wieder nen Reaper.
Hinter uns der Genji.
Ich muss die Orisa mal heilen.
Die checkt's nicht, die geht nicht weg.
So, ich bin auf dir.
Siehst du was?
Ja, irgendwo ist noch ein Reaper.
Ich hör rechts was.
Hinter uns, Reaper, hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns.
Nein, 1 HP.
Geh zurück und spawn.
Was? Du? Warum?
Weil man dich schießen kann.
Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Easy clap, easy clap.
Juust Mercy plays, Juust Mercy plays.
Oh Gott, diese Sch...
Ahh, Moira ist so ein Drecks...
Ding, ey.
Ah, super.
Was?
Was willst, was willst du wenig?
Hä, wenig was?
Nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, help, help, help, help.
Wo bist du?
Ein Stück da.
Damage boost.
Ich bleib jetzt auf dir wieder.
Beste Taktik.
Ah, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
So, easy, easy mode.
So.
Ich geh mal spawnen, Rektangeln.
Wenig, du kannst doch Deutsch.
Red doch Deutsch mit mir.
Ich weiß nicht, was du willst.
Nein, nein.
Jetzt, gleich kommt der Ratz.
Huge Razz, huge Razz.
Komm, wir gehen high ground.
Ich bin schon da.
Easy, komm.
Merci.
Was?
Nein!
Ich hab Ulti gewastet, ich hab Ulti gewastet, lol.
Jetzt kommen die Counter Plays des Todes.
Ich hab Ulti gewastet.
Wasted, baited.
Meine Mercy Plays sind einfach legendär, wie man sieht.
Aber, nichtsdestotrotz, es war die beste Entscheidung,
dass, basiert auf Erfahrung der letzten Runde,
einfach Damage Boost durchgedrückt halten.
Richtig.
So.
Easy.
Tschüss, tmra66.
Weil mich wundert ist, was da abging, ey.
Die Mercy war AFK auf dem Spot, hat's irgendwie geheilt, stand still.
Ich nehme mir so eine Sekunde Zeit, ziehe auf den Kopf, drück ab.
Oh, you shot.
Hä?
Komisch.
Weiß er nicht.
Enough waiting around.
Ich bleib bei uns stehen, wieder gesniped zu werden.
Ich hab zum ersten Mal jetzt gecheckt, dass man mit Mercy Space gedrückt halten kann,
zum Gleiten.
Greetings.
Ich bleib jetzt hier stehen, da kann mir nix passieren.
Easy.
Orisa, wie wär's mit nem zweiten Schild?
Hä, Orisa?
Nein, wollen wir nicht.
Tracer, ich hab ne Tracer rechts gehört.
Rechts, Tracer.
Ist ätzend, ne?
Komm, jetzt links, einer.
Rechts ist die Tracer wieder.
Boost ist auf dir drauf.
Ey, stopp.
Achtung, zu dir.
Weißt du mich?
Ja, ja, bin drauf.
Achtung, die Tracer ist rechts.
Fuck.
Hä?
Warum ging der Hex jetzt nicht?
Ich hab doch eh gedrückt.
Darf man sich da nicht bewegen, oder was?
Weißt du das?
Auf jeden Fall war's das jetzt.
Ja, jetzt gibt's Draw.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was soll ich denn da noch machen, ey?
Ich heal die ganze Zeit, aber...
Scheiß Börsemeter.
Ohne Witz.
Du hast einfach kein Paddel.
Bist dumm, ne?
Ja.
Nicht dumm.
Das ist mega zu gut so.
Moment, hier.
Gizzy, so.
Ja, die kommen rechts noch nicht.
Egal, du machst das schon.
Ich hab dich, ich hab Heal auf dich.
Das Börsemeter, das ist unglaublich dumm.
So ein Börse hab ich.
Versteck mich, ich muss mich verstecken.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, echt jetzt.
Echt jetzt.
Ey, das, das, das könnt ihr nicht machen, man.
Ich bin's, ich mach jetzt Soldier.
Wie viele soll ich denn noch killen?
Ich hab's, ich hab's.
Pass.
Hinter uns ist ein Genji am spawnen.
Hab ihn.
Äh, soll ich zurückswitchen?
Äh...
Ja, ja, ja.
Wobei wir echt ein DPS-Problem haben, also ich, ich hab so das Gefühl, ich bin komplett alleine.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Oben links kommt was.
Ich, ich komm zu dir zum Damage-Boosten.
Hast du nen Visor oder sowas?
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, oh, fuck.
Die haben mich übelst gedeift.
Rechte Seite.
Ich komm wieder mit Soldier.
Ich bleib Soldier.
So, 24 Minuten für den Job.
Jawoll!
Yeah!
Beste Runde.
Dokmimi, moin.
Ich, ich seh's schon, du hast Mercy Main Channels abonniert.
Was soll ich dazu sagen, Dokmimi, ha?
Das war, das war übrigens grade die Königsdisziplin, ne?
Das war 2CP, Mercy, Gameplay und Raw.
Das...
Äh, also...
Oh, fuck.
Ich hab...
Also, mein, mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht verlangen von diesem Game.
Das ist auch krass.
Bis gleich.
Oh, fuck.
Äh, äh, äh, ich hab...
Also, mein, mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht verlangen von diesem Game.
Das ist auch krass.
Bis gleich.
Das...
Äh, also...
Nur 2 Minuten.
Oh, fuck.
Ja, äh, äh, ich hab...
Also, mein, mehr kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht verlangen von diesem Game.
Das ist auch krass.
Bis gleich.
Dokmimi, ich hab nix gegen Mercy Mains.
Ich frag mich nur, wo die Mercy Mains in meinen Games sind, dann müsste ich nicht Mercy spielen.
Ich, ich finde Mercy Mains super, solange sie bei mir im Game sind.
Danke für die Follows.
Ich hab ein Twitch Achievement unlocked.
Teilzeit, Vollzeit und Vollzeit.
Überstunden 1.
Okay, was sagt dieses Achievement?
Dieses Achievement sagt,
Teilzeit, Vollzeit,
Überstunden.
Streame innerhalb von 30 Tagen insgesamt 25 Stunden.
Wo Hio.
Streame regelmäßig, um weitere Zuschauer anzulocken.
Finde dabei die richtige Balance
für dich.
Krasser Lifehack.
Dass ich die richtige Balance
für mich finden muss beim Streamen, ist schon...
Ist mein Plan.
Mein Plan.
Also, Eisberger, was für ein Rank wirst du?
Inosaki.
Es geht ja gerade darum, dass ich ein bisschen wieder in das Game reinkomme.
Wenn wir uns jetzt da
die Top 500 Spieler oder so holen.
Boah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, der Eax ist auch nicht so weit von Top 500 entfernt.
Dann ist ja der Lerneffekt nicht da.
Der Lerneffekt ist auch nicht da,
wenn ich die ganze Zeit Mercy spielen muss.
Allein nicht Mercy.
Ach, ich will Mercy nicht lernen.
Kommst du da, ist Kratz.
Geht's nicht.
Gut Job, GZ.
So, Eax ist weg.
Oh, bis er da ist,
was haben wir hier für Musik?
Beste.
Beste Party-Metal,
die es gibt.
Hey, hey.
Du kriegst gleich Banned. Warum krieg ich Banned?
Ich bin doch nicht euer Partner.
Warum soll ich gebannt werden?
Also nicht ich, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Lol.
Okay, ich muss erst mal Musik ausmachen.
Ja, mit dem Friseur.
Nehme ich im Dezember was auf.
Next.
Mit dem Kabu, muss ich mal gucken,
habe ich noch nicht gefragt.
Denke ich auch.
Ich habe eh, wie gesagt,
ich habe eh vor diesem Monat
einiges aufzunehmen mit mehreren Leuten.
Ihr braucht deinen Mercy-One-Trick-Pony.
Bin zwar noch keins, kann aber noch werden.
Wenn du das wirklich machen willst,
dann viel Spaß.
Ich kann es dir nicht empfehlen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das hat mir jetzt schon eine ziemliche Weile,
aber ich glaube,
du hast mal so 120 Punkt plus gemacht.
Ja.
Das sind halt die übelsten Diamond-Accounts.
Das dauert halt erst mal ein bisschen.
Jetzt habe ich eine Statistik.
18 Lost, 24 Won.
Das ist nicht so, oder was?
Es ist nicht so, dass du da hier
erst mal 80, 80 SR-Boost kriegen wirst,
das Programm.
Aber du kommst da halt nur mit Grind raus.
Weil es einfach total random ist.
Mittlerweile, was du so kriegst.
Ich meine, klar, im Durchschnitt kann man immer noch sagen,
ja, wenn du lang genug spielst
und immer alles skippst,
dann hast du genauso viele Scheiß-Gegner gegen dich,
wie du im eigenen Team hast und bla bla bla.
Aber ehrlich,
wenn du nicht gerade richtig guter Tracer,
Genji-Spieler oder sowas bist,
ist das wirklich,
ist halt harter Grind,
der echt frustrierend ist.
Klar, man kommt raus.
Jeden tut das.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich fand das früher aber wesentlich einfacher hochzukommen.
Ja, in Zeiten von Anna-Meta zum Beispiel,
da konntest du,
wenn du Anna gut gespielt hast,
also von Bronze bis GM konntest du Anna spielen.
Easy.
Nein, generell.
Also in Zeiten, wo einfach keine Mercy da war,
die ziehen Ultimatre immer.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das Frustrierende daran ist halt auch,
dass selbst, wenn du jetzt ein richtig geiles Play gemacht hast,
kommt die Mercy, drückt eine Taste,
das war für den Arsch.
Das ist halt echt das,
das ist auch wirklich das Frustrierende,
dagegen zu spielen.
Mal angenommen, du machst jetzt,
letztes Match ist Widow,
machst den übelst geilen hier Flick,
Headshot, sonst was,
Bam, Gegner tot,
wichtiges Target tot,
Mercy Highskill E.
So.
Fertig.
Du musstest halt die übelste Sache aufwenden.
Der Shatter 2K.
Bestimmter Real Shatter 2K.
Nein, ich spiel keine Mercy diesmal.
Ich seh's, ich seh's kommen, ich seh's kommen.
Ich seh's, nein.
Also wenigstens zwei Offtanks.
Wir sind ein Dual-Cremate, du hast ein Offtanks.
Wir Ego-Maten haben wir hier.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit Mercy gespielt.
Ich geh mal in den Teamchat,
ob die ein bisschen rumdingsen.
Wir haben beste, beste Voraussetzungen
mit dieser Comp, ja.
Ich seh's kommen, ich muss, ich muss jetzt.
Lass dich mal überraschen,
vielleicht gewinnen wir das sogar mit der scheiß Combo.
Also ich kann doch nicht permanent Mercy spielen.
An den Storl ich ja, obwohl wir gewinnen.
Vier DD und zwei Tanks.
Das ist ja perfektes, perfektes Setup hier, perfekt.
Warum hab ich eigentlich so ein Kack-Fadenkreuz beim Roadhog?
Kein Wunder, dass ich kein Hoax treffe.
Die, die, die sind hart drauf, oder?
Die wollen das jetzt wirklich spielen mit zwei Tanks und,
und No Heal.
Okay, er hat eine Ana geswitcht.
Einen Support hab ich raus.
Ah, Heal so an.
Ach nee, Mercy hat E gedrückt.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich gesagt hab.
Was?
Wie Orisa einfach mal pre-chumpt, so ohne zu wissen, was Sache ist.
Fuh!
Heal!
Gibt kein Heal.
Das ist wieder so ein Game, äh, was ist das hier?
Was ist das hier?
Oh, ETF.
Das ist eigentlich schon so ein Game, was fast schon wieder lost ist vom Anfang an.
Kannst du da auch nichts machen.
Was willst du da machen?
Du machst da ein Orisa-Shield da und da kommt schon das nächste.
Ja.
Das ist echt lächerlich gerade, ETR.
Mein Gott.
Ich mein, da kannst du halt nichts machen jetzt.
Das ist nicht möglich da was.
Was ist deine Peak-Max?
3000.
Was hatte ich Season 3 auf dem End?
3900?
4050?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Ocarina.
Wird natürlich gleich gerätzt.
Yeah, toll!
Hm.
Ich sag dir das.
Das Game hat viel zu viele Noob-Helden mittlerweile.
Was?
Was war das denn jetzt?
Nice.
Oh, ich dachte, das hast du gescoped gerade.
Nee.
Das ist echt hardcore lächerlich gerade.
Ey, das gibt's doch nicht!
Perfekt.
Perfektes Game.
Beste.
Bestes Game heute des Tages.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal Windows-Update gezogen?
Wann das?
Vorgestern oder so?
Perfekt.
Oh.
Das ist halt, das ist so ein typisches Game, das ist Instant, das ist Lost von Anfang an.
Das ist einfach Instant Lost.
Ah, so komplett Lost ist es ja nicht.
Aber ich hab jetzt auch keinen Bock gegen so eine Kombo irgendwie was Ernsthaftes zu picken.
Also, wenn du schon siehst, dass Instant erst mal die tolle 2-Tank-4-DPS-Kombo an den Start gebracht wird.
Nee, nicht deswegen.
Was meinst du?
Ich bin ja dieses ganze Schild rumgespannter.
Gibt mir keinen auf den Sack.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben eine gescheite, eine gescheite Komp.
Hätten wir das mal im Attack gehabt.
Solo-Heal.
Komm, das ist allemal besser als den Kack, den wir im Attack hatten.
Ohne Schild, ohne Heal. Irgendwann dann eine Ana.
Hallo, Eiskäuter.
Answer, das ist kein Salz, das ist Fakt.
Seit wann ist 2 Tanks, 4 DPS eine gute Spielbar?
Komp.
Und ich seh's auch nicht ein, immer den Held zu spielen mit Mercy, den ich am wenigsten gerne spiele.
Also immer. Das waren die letzten, die letzten 4 Games oder so.
Bin ich ja auch immer mega zum Kotzen auf meinem Main.
Eigentlich picke ich ja immer das, was, äh, kein anderer spielt.
Was macht eigentlich die Orisa da? Ich glaub, die will jetzt einfach da stehen bleiben und loosen, oder?
Ja.
Und der Junk ist am Frieden.
Okay, easy.
Beste, bestes Aim aller Zeiten.
Ey, was geht denn hier ab?
Die sterben einfach nicht mehr.
Egal, das Game ist vorbei. Easy Win.
Easy Win.
Der Junk, ey. Der Junk.
So, kannst du da weiterqueuen?
Ja.
Naja, gescheite, Komp geht anders. Hast du gesehen, mit was wir attackt haben?
Comments.
2 Tanks, 4 DPS. Perfekt.
Das sind so Games, die sind von Anfang an halt für'n Arsch.
Ey, wir spielen jetzt nicht mehr mit, als mit 2 Leuten.
Dual-Games.
Ja.
Dual-Q ist das höchste der Gefühle.
Theoretisch könntest du dir dann auch sagen, spielst du 6-Stack, gewinnst du alles.
Bis zu einem gewissen Rang, aber dann kriegst du kein SR.
Wenn du einen hohen SR hast, so diese ganzen Cheese-Leute, die einen hohen SR haben und dann erstmal im 6-Stack rumgabeln und ein Game die Woche machen.
Auf dem Account, dass sie oben bleiben.
Das hat's ja damals Evermore gemacht.
Kannst du dich noch erinnern? Dieser 5K Roadhog?
Ja.
Hat er hochgespielt und hat halt auch mit übelst guten Leuten gespielt. Dann hat er ein Game die Woche gemacht mit 6-Stack.
Zum Halten.
Haben wir jetzt diesmal Leute dabei?
Haben wir, ich guck mal, ob wir einen Support-Spieler haben.
Mercy-Main.
Pra... Praeletus.
Ja, viel Spaß jetzt, Hank.
Ah, easy.
Jetzt werden wir geflamed.
Jetzt werden wir geflamed, lol.
Jetzt haben wir als...
Jetzt haben wir ne...
Moira-Zen-Kombi.
Naja, ich mein, besser als nix, ne?
Ja, im Prinzip ist es ja nix.
Wenn gepickt wird, schon verloren.
Vor allem wir sind dran schuld in der letzten Runde, eindeutig.
Hat man ja gesehen, aber...
Äh, Ensner, der Evermore, der auf Gamescom Pupke gewonnen hat, kann sogar sein.
Der hat gesagt, er will als Pupke spielen.
Brauchen wir mal.
Es ist eh gleich.
Komm, ich werd weggesniped, dann haben wir keinen Rest.
Gut möglich.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1...
Fuck, der Grappling-Hook manchmal.
Ich dropp dann gleich runter.
So, ich conteste jetzt.
Ich muss weg.
Schießt unser Junkrat eigentlich Granaten, oder?
Ich brauch Heal!
Oh, sleep, fuck.
Heal, please, heal, please.
Wir haben halt kaum Heal.
Das ist definitiv nicht der real Shatter.
Ich bleib am Payload stehen.
Alter, ein Orb auf dem Winston, und er ist einfach mit.
So.
Ich brauch Heal!
Was haben wir denn jetzt gerade für Games?
Was ist das denn hier?
Zen, willst du nicht zurückgehen?
So, Leute, ich geh jetzt vor.
Tracer fast down.
Jetzt sind wir schön gegeneinander gecharged.
Warum krieg ich denn keine Heals?
Das gibt's doch nicht!
Und warum stirbt der Reinhardt nicht, obwohl er gestunt ist?
Das ist ja gerade schrecklich.
Das ist unglaublich, was der hier macht.
Das ist ja gerade schrecklich, was der hier macht.
Das ist unglaublich, oder?
Frag mich, was die meiste Heilung momentan ist.
600 oder so?
Oh!
Outplayed hat er mich, der Reinhardt.
Echt jetzt?
Jetzt haben wir überhaupt keinen Heiler mehr.
Oh Mann!
Was sind das denn für Spezialisten wieder?
Was sind das denn für Spezialisten?
Okay, so kann ich keinen Reinhardt spielen, das funktioniert nicht.
Jetzt kannst du vollknicken.
Hallo, Roadhog, fetter Sack.
Spring da mal hoch.
Ich hör einen Winston rechts von uns.
Und ich hör hier eine Tracer drin.
Wir müssen jetzt contesten.
Wir müssen contesten.
Nice, nice, Snipe-Sore.
Warum hat er das überlebt?
Winston links, ist ja extrem low.
Meine Güte, ey.
Was ist denn hier los?
Kann das... Warum...
Fünf. Fünf.
Junkrat, Spamme da.
Ich stehe hier gleich down.
Ich höre links, was?
Hook, Accuracy 29%.
Richtig krasser Hook, diese Runde.
Oh, schöne Nade von der Ana.
Ich weiß das schon wieder hinter mir, ey.
Was? Sie ist down.
Teste.
Wenigstens weg.
Oh Gott, das gibt es ja, dass ich daran sterbe,
obwohl ich den Heal-Strahl drauf habe.
Huge.
Huge Tire.
Huge. Big. Fett.
Massive.
Was für eine Runde, ey.
Aber vom Flamen her,
kann es echt ein Shatter sein, das hat er sich abgeguckt.
Ist auch immer am Flamen.
Wenn er mal strebend.
Can we have a proper comp?
Anscheinend nicht.
Soll ich es machen?
Was denn?
Warte mal.
Nein.
Mit den 2 Heilern hast du eh keinen Heiler.
Da kannst du immer was hier reinpicken.
Ja, machst meinen Personal Damage Booster.
Das wird schon reichen.
Genau.
Du musst jetzt noch einen Chat reinschreiben.
Personal Damage Booster.
Ist es egal, was ihr in den Chat schreibt,
dann ist instant das Geflame angesagt.
Ich hoffe, meine Gegner
nutzen hier keine Schilds beim Scheiße.
Das ist so.
Kann man in Overwatch auch ohne Team
ein bisschen was reißen?
Es macht auf jeden Fall mit Team am meisten Spaß.
So viel kann man sagen, denke ich.
Du kannst Solo-Kill spielen,
aber
die Erfüllung ist das auch nicht.
Da muss man halt ab und zu mal
einen sauren Apfel beißen und den Held spielen,
den man
am wenigsten mag, am wenigsten kann,
was auch immer bei Mercy so
alles zu können gibt.
Und da muss man halt durch.
Oh Gott, ey.
Ich seh dich schon.
Ich muss den Hawk heilen.
Sag, wenn du Heal
brauchst.
Auch hier?
Links, links ist der Hawk.
Links der Hawk.
Fress mich, fress mich.
Easy.
High Octane Mercy Gameplay.
Oh, oh.
Hawk hier, Hawk hier.
Ich komm zu dir.
Mach weg.
Pass auf, ich hab Angst vorm Hawk.
Ich brauch hier.
Helfer, Helfer.
Oh Gott, Mercy.
Ich hasse diese Helfer.
So komplett Dislike.
Vor allem, es gibt so viele Mercy-Mains.
Wo sind die alle?
Jetzt wieder, jetzt wieder.
Bleib auf mir drauf, bitte.
Okay.
Ja, ist halt echt so.
Wenn ich's nicht mach, dann macht's keiner.
Achtung, der Zen.
Der Zen muss jetzt, der wird gepoppt.
Bam, bam.
Alter, jawoll.
Ey, ich hab einen Winston.
Ah, ich muss hoch zu dir.
Bleib hier, bleib hier.
Nein, er wird auch geil.
Nein.
Der Hanzo hat mich geownt.
High Octane Mercy Gameplay.
Oh Mann.
Dieser Held.
Kriegst du das nicht mit, wenn ich das spät?
Doch, krieg ich mit.
Hanzo ist weg.
Junk ist weg.
Winston low, Winston down.
Da, guck, ich sag doch, wenn ich das nicht mach...
Ich seh dich grad nicht von hier aus.
Da kommen jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr.
Achtung, bei dir oben ist ein Hanzo.
Nice, nice, nice.
Schwede ey.
Das waren die sickest Shots des Todes, Mann.
Gleich klippen.
Kannst du mich mal hochfliegen lassen zu dir?
Ich versteck mich.
Ich hab Schiss.
Kommen die unten?
Ja.
Shit.
Kannst du mich reißen?
Äh, na...
Äh...
Pass auf, Tjana.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen heilen vorne.
Ja, die Moira macht grade Damage an einem Junkrat.
VIP-Aufgabe.
Hallo, Leute, ich muss euch sehen, dass ich euch heilen kann, ne?
Ich bin, ich bin weggekickt worden von...
Vom Affe.
Harambe.
Easy win, easy win.
Kaum spielst du Mercy, ne?
Kaum spielst du diesen Kackheld.
Nicht lieben, bitte.
Das ist Podge.
Ja, zeig Podge her.
Ach, komm.
Bleib trotzdem drinnen.
Ich will die Karte sehen.
Ähm...
Kommt noch Battlefield 3?
Äh...
Nein.
Heute nicht.
Es ist 0 Uhr 22 und ich fang jetzt kein neues Game mehr an.
Eisberger, bist du nicht sogar Mod beim Friseur?
Streamt der Friseur auf Twitch?
Ja.
By the way, ich hab dich von den SR fast eingeholt, ne?
Nice.
Und das, obwohl wir zusammenspielen.
Gib mal noch einen Tag, dann können wir nicht mehr mehr queuen.
Ähm...
Zeig mal her.
Schick.
Welche...
Ich glaube, ich war sogar ein bisschen höher, oder?
Ja, ja.
Du hattest, wo wir angefangen hatten, 150.95.
Ich sehste.
So, die sicken Mercy-Plays haben es ja nicht mal gelohnt.
Nee.
Die personelle SR-Performance ist ja zum Glück bald weg.
Ja.
Ich bin echt froh.
Ich bin schon traurig.
Und...
Es ist so absurd, dass das Game keine Team-Queue hat.
Ich versteh das nicht.
Ich meine, es macht mit Abstand am meisten Spaß im Team.
Das sagt ja Jeff Kaplan selbst sogar.
Es ist ein Spiel, was gedacht ist, im Team zu spielen, und da gibt es keine Team-Queue.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Blizzard-Logic.
Blizzard, ja.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Er hat ja vor über einem Jahr schon gesagt, sie wollen an einem Clan-System oder sie arbeiten an einem Clan-System.
Das wäre ja sowas.
Kannst du quasi...
Machst du dir halt kein Six-Stack, sondern machst dir halt so ein Pool aus ein paar Spielern, weißt du, mit denen du dann queuest und so.
Das könnte man doch machen.
Wäre doch top.
Ja, macht schon.
Also, ich find's ja ganz gut, was sie mit dem Game machen, aber sie machen's halt nicht viel zu langsam.
Yes, yes.
Schön.
Komm, ich spiel mal wieder Speed.
Reihen.
Wie das war.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal die Stats vom real Shatter2K an.
Er hat circa 50-50 Win-Loss auf Diamond.
Ja, das ist bestimmter real Shatter2K.
Warum sind eigentlich alle so geil darauf, Moira zu spielen?
Äh, die ist ein großer Laserstrahl.
Und neuer Held.
Wahrscheinlich.
Need Mercy.
Außer dem Laserstrahl kann ich mir nichts vorstellen.
Ich krieg...
Ich...
Flip aus.
Ich kann nicht noch mal Mercy spielen.
Ja, wenn da einer sagt, take Mercy, du musst sie schreiben, dann nimm sie doch.
Na ja, guck mal.
Wir haben jetzt Anna.
Ey, wie lange war ich nicht mehr der Erste auf dem Spot?
Schon Jahrzehnte her.
Ich hab rechts was gehört.
Oben links ist auch.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ganz schön viel hier.
Ich seh keinen Gegner.
Rechtsseite, rechtsseite.
Oh!
Was war das für ein Hook?
Der Hawk steht mir auf dem Kopf.
Ja, lasst euch farmen.
Nein!
Genji ist okay.
Ich hab Ulti.
Warum...
Warum, Leute?
Kannst du mich killen?
Der Moira Ball hat mich fast gekillt.
Ja, mach ich.
Ich muss unseren Harambe, der sich jetzt gerade hinter der Säule versteckt hat...
Hast du nicht abgekriegt?
Nö.
Oh, wie knapp, wie knapp.
Hätte nur einer mehr draufgeschossen auf dieses Teil, er wär's weg gewesen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wieder da.
Hectorino.
Irgendwo haben die einen Sniper.
Ich weiß nicht wo, oben links vielleicht?
Nee, unten links.
Jetzt.
Ey.
Ich hab Heal an, mehr kann ich nicht machen.
Haha!
Boostio!
Endlich mal wieder.
Lange nicht mehr gehabt.
Endlich mal wieder Boostio.
Ich wurd bestimmt schon seit 5 Monaten nicht mehr geboostet.
Links oben.
Ja, ich geh in die Mitte.
Ja, das ist ganz gut.
Kannst von da was schnipsern.
Die kommen ja nicht mehr raus.
Ich muss Heal laufen lassen.
Steht das nicht?
Ich schieß auf den Kopf.
Saria ist fast down.
Ich hab sie.
Die Gegner, die Gegner werden aber ganz schön weggefickt gerade.
Oh nein!
Gerade hier oben liegt eine Trap.
Alter.
Ich bin hier außen.
Ich leb noch, ich leb noch.
Ich komm zurück.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Ich komm zu gar nichts.
Ich hab Ulti.
Huge Ult.
Nice.
Ich geh jetzt wechseln.
Jetzt hab ich den aufgeweckt.
Haben wir den?
Ja, ich hab den.
Ich hab den.
Oh.
Das ist sie, die jetzt drüben liegt.
Die These ist der Linsen.
Ist nicht?
Jetzt müssen wir aber drauf.
Go, go, go, Leute.
Boah, diese Dreck.
Das gibt's doch nicht!
Da schießt auch keiner druf, oder so.
Bäm!
Drecksmap.
Wir hätten die bei einigen Files einschaben müssen.
Was wir Mercy machen, Pocket.
Ja, okay.
Brau, let's break it down, tryhard, ja.
So spielt sie so scheiße King of the Hill ohne Lucian.
Spielt sie fast schon wie 2CP.
Die sterben.
Rekt?
Rekt.
Ich muss mal unsere Orisa heilen, kurz.
Sag mal, was macht denn der Rest vom Team?
Gute Frage.
Das ist nicht normal.
Das versteh ich auch nicht.
Wie konnte man das denn jetzt verlieren, Alter?
Oh man.
Ich bin übrigens in der Mitte, ne?
Aber das ist mir jetzt egal.
Weg damit.
Huge Mercy Blaze.
Hinter uns, hinter uns.
Andere Seite.
Außen.
Ich muss weg.
Rechts kommt was, rechts kommt was.
Tschö.
Weißt du.
Nice!
Wer ist denn der Rest vom Gegner?
Weiß nicht.
Ich muss den Typen erretzen.
Und mich heilen.
Was ist so braindead, KKR?
Gleich kommt Huge, Alti.
Huge.
Bist du Fan?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Huge, Alti.
Huge.
Zwar Massive war das.
Hahaha, was ne Runde.
Was ne Runde.
Moins, moins, Sonix.
Jawoll.
Jetzt.
Jetzt geht's ab, ja.
Easy.
Wobei das andere geiler war.
Huge kills.
Huge Mercy Blaze.
Ist wirklich schlimm, dass man so viel Mercy spielen muss.
Wundert mich.
So aus Streams, wie ich sonst so gucke, ist ja alles voll mit irgendwelchen Mercy Mains.
Aber hier ist es so schlimm, dass es nicht mehr Mercy gibt.
So.
Wie vorhin schon gesagt, die sind alle zu Grandmaster.
Die sind alle zu Grandmaster.
Ich würde sagen, machen wir morgen weiter.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Nein, ich bin jetzt auch.
Oh, es reicht.
Hast du auch noch Runde Plus gemacht.
Easy.
Wie viel hast du jetzt?
Ich habe jetzt hier Ende 3226.
Du müsstest ja ein bisschen mehr haben.
3189.
Ach, ich dachte, du hast mich überholt jetzt.
Aber ich kann ja selbst gucken.
Ich guck mal.
Ach, ich habe gerade auch ein Update-Knock.
Keine gute Idee.
Ja, 3189.
Ja, das passt doch.
So, huge.
Huge Blaze heute, Chat.
So, gibt es irgendjemanden, den man hosten kann jetzt noch?
Mal gucken.
Overwatch, wer ist denn hier am Start?
Kamikaze, den können wir hosten.
Der freut sich bestimmt.
Also, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
So.
Richtig braindead jetzt.
Oh, nicht mal eine Benachrichtigung drin.
Doch, hat er.
Wuppelslor.
Der weiß doch sogar, dass ich das bin.
Lol.
Lipstream.